what's up guys michael here to talk
about the high school show that has
parents confiscating body glitter all
over the country that's right euphoria
it provokes vivid reactions whether
people are crying over roo's latest
relapse squirming at nate's improbable
awfulness or counting on-screen dongs
like pokemon euphoria has garnered
plenty of praise for its expressive
cinematography and raw treatment of
contemporary high school life but not
without controversy some say it
glorifies teen drug use and other
naughty behaviors others argue that it
puts the audience through the emotional
ringer without substantial payoff but
whether you think this is prestige
television at its best or trauma porn at
its most shameless chances are you
probably agree that watching the show
feels something like getting kicked in
the stomach by a runaway donkey in a
crop top now it's not like the show's
various themes from addiction to
queerness can't be found elsewhere on
television but on euphoria everything
from painful trauma to the most minor
adolescent dignity viscerally hurts are
you making fun of me or did you actually
think i was auditioning for oklahoma so
what exactly makes the show so gutting
let's explore in this wisecrack edition
on euphoria empathy is work
and of course spoilers ahead for
euphoria
when we think about the standout moments
on euphoria they are typically the ones
that are most painful take for example
cassie's anxiety-driven borderline
violent grooming behaviors to attract
nate i have never ever been happier or
rue bailey out of her mom's car and
going on the lamb to avoid going back to
rehab as her sister jia screams and
panic to understand why scenes like
these are so stressful to endure we need
to bring in the concept of empathy i.e
the ability to understand and share the
feelings of another well philosophers
had kicked this idea around for
centuries there wasn't a term for the
concept until german philosopher and art
historian robert fisher used the word
einfalung in 1873. translated to empathy
it would enter the popular consciousness
around the beginning of the 20th century
in this way empathy like joel's glittery
makeup has a distinctly modern flair
scholar jeremy rifkin attributes the
increasing importance of empathy to the
rise of modern psychology which
encouraged people to delve more deeply
into their own internal worlds thus
complicating their self-perceptions as
human beings began thinking more deeply
and in a more nuanced way about their
feelings and thoughts they also started
thinking about those feelings and
thoughts in relation to other people's
inner worlds as rivkin explains it
wasn't until human beings were developed
enough in human selfhood that they were
able to recognize the existence of
empathy that is to say properly
interpreting what's going on for rue
when she jumps out of that car first
requires you to understand your own
potentially self-destructive impulses
and how those impulses might be
perceived by other people as
psychologist and philosopher theodore
lips put it einfalung is the process of
tapping into the emotional subjectivity
of another person's psyche to the point
where you can't tell where your feelings
end and theirs begin like fallen into a
jules rue elliot cuddle puddle it
requires connecting to someone else on a
deeper level than we usually do but at
the same time the concept of empathy
took off modern society was encouraging
self-contained individuality as a result
empathy weirdly became more difficult
just because humans had discovered what
it meant to feel other people's
subjectivity it didn't mean we were good
at practicing it indeed studies have
shown that human beings still have a
tendency to see others especially say
people struggling with addiction or
overtly sexualized women as simple
abstractions rather than full complex
human beings we see this behavior plenty
in euphoria rue is commonly dismissed as
being just a junkie in all fairness last
summer there were like three weeks where
i thought you were dead or like when
cassie's potential hookup cruelly tells
her that any guy who says he's
interested in you beyond just you
is full of here both women are being
seen as simple abstractions based on one
aspect of their being their drug use or
their sexuality true empathy in contrast
requires seeing people as more than the
sum of their parts and attempting to
connect to their subjectivity as writer
elie wiesel put it we must not see any
person as an abstraction instead we must
see in every person a universe with its
own secrets with its own treasures with
its own sources of anguish and with some
measure of triumph perhaps
unsurprisingly due to their ability to
viscerally render characters in her
worlds film and later television have
long been considered useful mechanisms
for eliciting empathy as film critic
roger ebert once said for me the movies
are like a machine that generates
empathy now there's one good reason any
successful tv show needs to elicit
empathy people are more likely to keep
coming back week after week if they
actually give a [ __ ] about the
characters on screen but euphoria from
our view is different here empathy isn't
merely a mechanism to get people to
stick around it's the entire point of
the show euphoria most literally spells
this out when rue's narcotics anonymous
sponsor talks about the way society
reduces people struggling with addiction
to abstractions we're too busy
running around judging everybody's
intentions and motivations if we have
some insight into the human soul you
know you did this so that must mean
you're that just give me a break but
more subtly the intention of empathy is
telegraphed throughout the show's visual
and narrative devices take the episodes
which feature rue's voice over narration
she just knew that she had something
special
something intangible now the pilot
starts somewhat conventionally with rue
narrating her own life story i was once
happy content sloshing around in my own
private primordial pool though notably
it's evoking memories she couldn't
possibly have like being born and what
was on tv when she popped out this gives
it a surreal vibe and as the series
progresses that omniscience becomes more
uncanny as even the most minor of
characters are given a few minutes of
ruse narration or they could just sit in
silence
they were that close
that comfortable these segments are
divulged from a close third perspective
meaning it's presented in the third
person but skews closely to the
character's actual lived experience
rather than remaining entirely objective
like say a news reporter would
importantly for the most part rue is
narrating aspects of these characters
lives and inner worlds that she couldn't
possibly have access to this creates a
surreal sense of almost uber empathy it
also complicates the ways we think about
each character it forces us to
understand why each teen or adult makes
some unsavory choices and to reconsider
characters whom we might normally and
reflexively judge or dismiss what the
show seems to be saying about high
school and about life in general is
every person has [ __ ] going on that you
couldn't know simply from looking at
them or talking to them such is the
power of empathy it's also impossible to
talk about euphoria's production of
empathy without discussing its highly
stylized look and feel first off
euphoria trafficks heavily in one shots
especially intense close-ups which until
very recently were rarely seen on
television and still don't typically
show up on soapy teen shows the rise of
the close-up was a really important
transformation in film history early
film mostly used wide shots as if you
were watching a play but in a 1912 film
called friends we saw what film director
paul schroeder calls the first true
close-up one of actress mary pickford's
face this suddenly gave us access to far
more information about her emotional
condition it's perhaps no wonder then
that mary pickford became hollywood's
true first celebrity while actors and
actresses had previously gone uncredited
the rise of close-ups made audiences
start to relate to the performers as
people and thus
love them as much as you love tom daya
euphoria's close-ups are often slow in
searching typically featuring a face or
part of a face over a blurred out
background this gives viewers nothing
but that actor to engage with putting us
as close to understanding what the
character feels as visually possible but
when it's not making you want to barf in
the hot tub with cassie euphoria is also
using the kinds of high octane camera
movements you're more accustomed to
seeing in action films while being
highly cinematic such movements also
pump up our emotions the camera might
dive into a pool to express the
exuberance of a drunken house party or
it might slowly dolly back to emphasize
just how alone a character feels it
might defy gravity to help you get a
sense of what drugs feel like or of
course it might run uninterrupted
through a food cart around the grounds
of a carnival and ultimately up to a
ferris wheel showing the personal
intrigues and heartaches of each
character along the way the sequence in
particular reinforces one of the show's
key themes the characters are all in the
same place physically sure but they're
each in a complicated emotional universe
of their own such is the unadulterated
rollercoaster of teenage hormones and
some of those rollercoaster rides are
relentlessly long it's pretty well
accepted that lengthy shots can be super
effective in building tension more so
than quick cutaways that's why the
lingering shot and say every slasher
movie when you're waiting for the killer
to strike is so much scarier than the
actual slashing itself our instinct is
to look away in search of some emotional
relief by lingering almost unbearably
long in many of its shots euphoria
doesn't give us that relief instead like
a slasher film it makes us sit in the
moment as the tension builds but instead
of a scary guy with a knife the thing
we're confronting is the high intensity
emotions being felt by the characters
euphoria is also known for its endless
tracking chats which give it a feeling
of constant attention and surveillance
accumulating tension with each moment
which isn't all that different from how
it feels to be a teenager painfully
self-aware worried that everyone's
watching and judging you what's more the
colors are just as vivid as the camera
movements a bike ride to meet a crush
takes on a dreamy yellow palette that
evokes that ineffable sense of being in
a fairy tale the first time you fall in
love pinkish hues express the
overwhelming joy of an intoxicated night
out with friends and of course a dark
blue palette emphasizes the utter depths
of roo's depression often times in
modern cinema and television shaky
handheld camera movements are used to
evoke a point of view and literally put
you in the character's shoes in order to
better understand their experience but
euphoria's highly stylized choices do
something different they evoke the
character's outsized feelings about
their experiences as the creator sam
levinson explained he eschewed cinematic
realism and instead strove to make each
scene an interpretation of reality or a
representation of an emotional reality
each shot contributes to an emotional
sense of what the character is feeling
rather than the actual movements of
their everyday life critics sometimes
wonder why euphoria has to take place in
high school asking why the characters
couldn't just be 20 somethings with
fully developed frontal cortexes a
choice which would probably render the
show less controversial but the
emotional realism is key to
understanding why euphoria only makes
sense when set in high school when
you're a teenager all your emotions are
heightened to the nth degree love does
feel like being subsumed in a bath of
pink light having a drink does make the
world feel like it flipped over while we
might not have had the same experiences
as the way two experienced euphoria
teens have we can certainly relate to
the outsized feelings that we're
cinematically persuaded to share with
them but we still haven't fully
explained why empathy is so important to
understanding euphoria and its
perpetually troubled teens to piece that
together we need to look back to rifkin
who argues that we are in an era of
dramaturgical consciousness this means
we take a more theatrical view of life
and our identities all the world's a
stage in a society that's ardently
preoccupied with social media and
subsumed by surveillance it's no
surprise that teens glued to their
phones construct their lives with the
attention to detail of both audience and
director and those audiences and the
performances they expect to see
change with every interaction that means
we essentially construct and reconstruct
ourselves from interaction to
interaction like cal camwork brings out
a different side of cat as she plays the
role men seem to want now role playing
therapy where you act out different
personas to better understand your
psychological hang-ups was common
amongst the baby boomers in their young
adulthood but rifkin says role-playing
is no longer a therapeutic technique but
rather a form of consciousness like how
you play someone different on weird
twitter than in an email to your mom in
our increasingly digital reality we are
all constantly reconstructing and
re-understanding ourselves in every
interaction creating dispersed
identities that are more complex and
nuanced than the fixed understanding
people used to have about human nature
we see this in the narrative
construction of euphoria it shows each
character as complex and nuanced as they
negotiate their own identity sometimes
this is painful or uncomfortable who am
i
woof
wow wow
but by say showing even nate's father as
a young love struck man we experience a
different side of him one that isn't as
easy to dismiss as a chilly monster this
is the same way understanding rue's drug
addiction requires knowing how deeply
the loss of her father still weighs on
her characters who might be depicted as
unsympathetic flat and static on another
show are thus given more context to
facilitate our emotional concern for
them and euphoria's sense of radical
empathy extends to every character we'd
argue that's a pretty cool thing and
plenty of people would agree with us in
fact moralists like david hume and adam
smith even argued that empathy is a
prerequisite for morality they used the
word sympathy instead but essentially
described empathy this makes sense so
much of morality is about how you treat
other people and you can't treat people
well unless you understand and recognize
their complexities subjectivity and
humanity and when we don't do that it
becomes much easier to ignore systemic
issues like addiction homelessness
disease and even climate change empathy
is about more than isolated interactions
between individuals it's about seeing
the world ethically and the people who
populate that world not as ideas but as
complete human beings sometimes we even
see characters learning to do just that
on euphoria like when rue decides not to
run away with jewels because she's
learned to empathize with how much it
might hurt her mother and sister along
with rue the audience is also developing
empathy and that's why watching the show
can feel so exhausting empathy is hard
work and it's easier to judge people
based on abstractions than to genuinely
connect to them especially when you're
watching people on the silver screen
think about reality tv when someone gets
a villain at it an empathetic reaction
is about as likely as a bachelor and
paradise couple surviving their third
anniversary rue explicitly points out
the chronic lack of empathy in the world
everyone's just out to make everyone
else not seem human
i don't really want to be a part of it
rue's response as a nihilistic kid is
understandable but the only way to
surpass these kinds of hasty judgments
is empathy and when we do choose to be a
part of it it can be a rewarding and
uniquely modern experience but what do
you guys think is euphoria the most
compelling show on television is my
heart being broken every week for no
reason let us know in the comments big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our
podcast hit that subscribe button like
you're desperately pausing the tv when
your parents walk in and don't forget to
ring that bell and as always thanks for
watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]